the principle of specificity refers to
the widely accepted notion that the most
useful exercises are those that closely
match the activities they seek to train
this refers not only to biomechanics but
also energy systems and all other
aspects
in other words the best way to get
better at chopping wood is to practice
chopping wood
the next best way is to use the cable
wood chop bicep curls
not so useful a good sports coach must
therefore select their exercises
through the lens of specificity
alternatively a movement may be chosen
that develops the underlying physical
attributes
that contribute to that movement such as
isolation work for a crucial muscle
group
finally general physical preparedness
may be used insofar as it helps to
balance out the physique
prevent injury and contribute to an
overall more healthy individual
conditioning time is limited so every
exercise needs a good reason to exist in
the program
coaches will likewise typically increase
the specificity as they get closer to
the competition date
thus functional coaches like jc santana
of the institute of human performance
advocate for the use of exercises like
the truck push
in favor of squats for improving running
speeds and jumping heights
this is predicated on his observation
that the truck push involves
more similar joint angles and train such
attributes as ankle stiffness at
approximately 90 degrees
in short this provides what we refer to
as superior
transference the skill trained more
closely matches the intended outcome
squats aren't bad they're just
sub-optimal by comparison when the goal
is specifically
to improve running speed but not
everyone agrees that this is the best
strategy
there's an alternative viewpoint that
training with exercises too similar to
the skills targeted
could actually be detrimental to an
athlete's performance
the reason for this being that they may
lead to interference
interference means that a new skill or
movement pattern can actually complicate
an existing one two similar movement
patterns could conceivably confuse the
athlete
causing them to harm their own
performance critics of functional
training such as mark riptoe
thus argue that the better strategy is
to train an athlete's general strength
and then to pile skills training on top
of that ripton his followers
believe that the compound barbell lifts
are all you need alongside skills
training
crypto believes that strength is a
universal property that you're either
strong
or you're not and that thus being strong
in the squat means you're strong
full stop he also believes that traits
like higher fast twitch fibers
are so largely genetic that all we can
do is to train for strength and hope
that that helps our skill
this i believe is misguided neural maps
aside
the truth is that the traditional
barbell lefts alone
failed to train the different planes of
motion and myriad muscles involved
in useful movements generally as agreed
for example that twitch fiber density
is roughly 50 genetically predetermined
that leaves 50
wiggle room fascinatingly our level of
plasticity itself
also actually seems to be genetic to an
extent and other things like blood
supply tendon hysteresis all of these
can be trained to an extent
and many of these aspects also
contribute to explosiveness
more to the point if strength gains
really were global bodybuilders wouldn't
need to train with isolation
in fact you would only need one exercise
you could just perform the squat
the simple fact is that you can't get
stronger obliques without some form of
twisting
or at least antilateral flexion without
using the muscle group in question
you can't expect to cause metabolic
stress muscle damage etc
and the notion that squats and other
compound moves trigger such a huge
release of testosterone that it results
in more muscle building throughout the
body
is actually also mistaken the surgeon
testosterone we see during training is
temporary
like the surge experience when watching
an action movie and there are studies
showing that this does not contribute to
hypertrophy
if you want to see these studies for any
of this then click on the link in the
description down below where you'll find
the full article on my website
and that includes links to all of the
relevant studies
even the bioenergetic properties of
heavy lifting are ineffective for most
sports and exercises
training endurance and work capacity
would undoubtedly be more useful for the
vast majority of competitive sports
if you had to choose this is not to say
squatting is useless far from it
squats improve mobility they build core
strength they develop amazing strength
in the posterior chain
and they increase bone density but they
alone are not sufficient to provide the
necessary one-legged strength
the stability tendon hysteresis etc that
is necessary for optimal
athletic training something like
skipping car pushes hill sprints or
similar on the other hand
do provide those necessary attributes
and traits
and yet interference is a known
phenomenon amongst neuroscientists we
can't just write this off
it's referred to in the context of
memory retrieval in particular but it's
also believed to affect motor learning
think about learning two new languages
at once or even switching from the
controls of one computer game to another
how about when the y-axis is inverted
one study possibly demonstrates the
interference principle in action
here professional swimmers were found to
have a lower jumping height than members
of the general population
even those considered to be unathletic
so does training with exercises that
more closely mimic the desired movement
actually confused the neural maps is
there some kind of strange grey area
where a movement is too specific
but without being specific enough there
is good evidence showing that the sled's
pull
does improve running speed ground
contact time and stride length
this same study also showed that the
benefits were greatest when pulling
approximately 75
of body weight as this increased the
athlete slowed down
and the technique changed resulting in
less performance again a subtle
difference in training
drastically alters the outcomes where do
we draw the line
one consideration is that different
sports may require differing levels of
specificity
the sprinter will use far more
consistent technique during every
competition
they are running in a straight line on a
flat consistent surface the same is true
for a rower
placed firmly on the spot and required
to perform the same rowing piston
movement with perfect precision
power and endurance compare this with a
football player who needs to constantly
change speed change direction
adjust to changes in the ground and
often all while dribbling a ball or
making split-second changes in tactics
the football player isn't learning one
set of biomechanics but rather infinite
unpredictable permutations but perhaps
the best technique
is no technique
that's because no two movements are ever
truly the same consider that when a row
arose every single stroke will be
affected by their levels of fatigue
in each individual motor unit altering
the recruitment and coordination of
muscles
they'll also be affected by the effort
of their teammates how still the water
is the wind the weight of the boat the
momentum from previous stroke
this is why no rowing machine could ever
truly match the experience of actually
rowing
we tend to think of force production as
being all about output
but this is far from the truth input is
equally important to refine the movement
producing the force
this is our motor perceptual landscape
and it is critical in all athletic
performance
and graceful movement so i ask you how
can a somewhat similar exercise
interfere with a movement pattern
that doesn't exist a movement pattern
that is in truth already an infinite
number of somewhat similar but slightly
different movement patterns
in fact how do we even manage to get out
of bed in the morning especially
considering the huge number of forces
acting on us
and the insane amount of coordination
necessary between different joints and
muscles
and keep in mind that we're starting off
in a slightly different position every
time we get up
this is what nikolai bernstein refers to
as the degrees of freedom problem
he concluded that we store general
movement patterns rather than specific
techniques
he further states that the more
generalized these become the more robust
and broadly applicable they will be
thus to train an athlete optimally you
should not only train them under ideal
conditions
but also with countless different
variations to help them adapt their
skills
and use them in a helpful and realistic
manner run when tired
run on wet surfaces run on dry surfaces
change direction quickly
run in unusual shoes dynamical systems
theory helps us to further understand
this
this explanation describes the body as
being comprised of self-organizing
systems
that arrange themselves around three
major constraints
environment goals and organism in other
words
every movement must be a direct response
to these forces
which once again vary every time this
helps us to narrow down the perfect
movement for the situation
your body knows which version of the
movement pattern to utilize because it
is guided by your objectives
and the shape of the environment input
and output
so as soon as you raise your hand up to
start pushing the truck your body
recognizes this as a different movement
and selects the correct pattern
important though is to introduce these
new variables in training
only once the basic movement pattern has
been mastered this provides the stable
base to build off from
once the movement is mastered then more
variables can be introduced in order to
test the limits of that new skill
failing to do this is one way in which
specificity can be misapplied
by introducing variations too early or
too late in the learning process
in other words we need to learn to walk
before we can run and to run
before we can car push but we see the
benefit of varying the precise mechanics
and context of a movement in other areas
too
context interference is another concept
from neuroscience and memory
that this time considers whether we
learn better through blocks of rote
repetition
of a single skill or by randomly
training different skills
out of sequence it turns out that the
latter option results in a short term
detriment
but longer term benefits that is to say
that by training in a more chaotic and
mixed-up manner
you actually improve skill acquisition
and transference in the long term
and just as a triathlete can become
extremely adept at running cycling and
swimming
just as you can run on sand without
forgetting how to run on tarmac just as
you can write the letter a
and the letter b and just as you can
differentiate between takeoff and
maintenance phases when running
what you may find is that early on in
the learning phase you do experience
confusion
and we see this in our day to day lives
too yes learning how to play doom may
initially create confusion
when you return to play call of duty but
if you practice both for long enough
you can become a master at both when i
first tried to learn to type on my new
mini laptop i found it difficult because
i become accustomed to writing
on the bigger keyboard just like the
swimmers might be referring to older
neural patterns
when trying to jump but now that i have
put in a good number of hours with both
keyboards i have no problem switching
from one to the other
none of this is to completely write off
anyone's personal experience of
interference
i'm not saying it doesn't exist everyone
is different and as you can see
this is not a straightforward discussion
it's predicated mostly on
observation and theory it may affect
some people some sports more than others
the point is that your brain is
remarkable and can adapt and that
tweaking the variables just enough
should help you to land on an exercise
that is optimal for your goals
with constant observation measurement
and iteration
my personal approach to training of
course is different i'm not interested
in training athletes to be the very best
at a controlled sport
most people watching this won't be
professional athletes
my interest is in training myself and
others to be as good at as many things
as possible
i'm interested in the strategies used by
functional coaches
because they are the masters at making
the athletes faster more endurant
or better at jumping higher they know
which exercises are optimal for those
activities
i want to see what exercises and
techniques i can take from those to
incorporate into my own training
i want to be fast as well as strong so
if i'm only squatting i may not be
getting the most possible benefits from
my training
but seeing as i want that bone density
and max strength i'm going to continue
to squat
as well consider for a moment that in
nature there is no such thing as a
technique
while certain sports may encourage us to
attempt to use nearly identical
techniques wherever possible
when moving through a natural
environment every movement will be
different
and your goals will be constantly
changing practicing a specific technique
is then in fact a human thing and not
entirely natural
and we certainly wouldn't repeat the
same movement over and over again for 10
reps
maybe it makes perfect sense that
performing a random sequence of
movements actually leads to better
transference
as that is how we practice movement in
reality
so perhaps a question to leave you on is
why should you repeat 10 reps of
anything
sure keeping the focus on one muscle
group will increase time and attention
and it will thus allow for more muscle
damage and metabolic stress
but you can still accomplish that with
slight variations of the same movement
instead of push-up push-up push-up
push-up what about push-up
archer push-up one-handed push-up
maltese push-up push-up
that still keeps the focus on the pecs
while being more creative and
challenging
something to consider if you're looking
for ways to mix up your training
so that was a fairly in-depth discussion
on functional training i hope you found
it interesting
if you did then you may be interested in
pre-ordering my book functional training
and beyond which is coming out next
month
that's a book that explores all the
concepts of functional training and how
they can be applied to all of our
lifestyles
alternatively if you're interested in
starting a more super functional form of
training right now
then i have an e-book and training
program that's linked in the description
down below and there's a discount on
right now
whilst many of us are in lockdown thanks
so much for watching this one i hope you
really enjoyed it i'm hoping to get one
out next week but we'll have to see how
it goes over the christmas period
thanks a ton for watching and
bye for now